[Música]
es una rabia que retumba en las calles
de seúl desde principios de marzo estos
surcoreanos dicen no a un proyecto de su
gobierno el objetivo del nuevo
presidente indemnizar a las víctimas de
trabajos forzados durante la ocupación
japonesa de la Península entre 1910 y
1945 una idea positiva en teoría pero es
el método el que está provocando un
escándalo el estado coreano quiere que
sean sus propias empresas indemnizadas
en el pasado por Japón las que paguen el
dinero según también pide un gesto a las
empresas japonesas sin embargo para
muchos coreanos pedirlo amablemente está
fuera de lugar no es tarea de Corea
pagar por los crímenes de Japón
para mejorar su imagen Japón debe
indemnizar a las víctimas de masacres
como la de mi abuelo
y también a las víctimas de trabajos
forzados
la Disculpa de Japón es una prioridad
porque algunas víctimas siguen vivas
antes de que mueran todos es necesaria
una disculpa Clara
A mediados de abril las familias de una
decena de víctimas fallecidas aceptaron
el plan del gobierno pero otras entre
ellas tres víctimas aún vivas rechazaron
la propuesta según Corea del Sur casi
780.000 coreanos fueron sometidos a
trabajos forzados Durante los 35 años de
ocupación japonesa
explotados y mal pagados o incluso sin
cobrar trabajaban para empresas
japonesas algunas de las cuales como
Mitsubishi Todavía existen
otro tema despierta más ira las mujeres
de solaz un eufemismo para referirse a
las coreanas prostituidas o violadas por
soldados japoneses algunas de ellas han
encontrado el valor de hablar de poner
palabras a un sufrimiento al que ahora
se enfrenta
Esta foto fue tomada la primera vez que
fui a Kawasaki
Caminé desde la iglesia de Kawasaki
hasta Tokio vestida de blanco como señal
de protesta
legion psoe es un adolescente cuando es
secuestrada por los ocupantes japoneses
para convertirse en una mujer desolad en
un barco japonés
una persona me dijo que fuera a la
habitación de un soldado Cuco
cuando dije que no iría me dijeron que
me matarían y me torturaron con
electricidad
mi cuerpo temblaba muy fuerte les rogué
que no me mataran en medio del horror La
niña se cruza con unos soldados
japoneses que la ayudan en secreto
cuando regresa a Corea oculta la
tragedia que ha vivido hoy quiere creer
en un acercamiento entre los dos países
Espero que esto se resuelva pronto
veo a Japón como nuestro vecino no como
nuestro enemigo
pasar la página pero no olvidar en el
sur del país este museo conserva la
memoria de esta tragedia Aunque
oficialmente se han identificado 240
coreanas víctimas seúl Calcula que entre
80.000 y 200.000 mujeres fueron
sometidas a estas atrocidades
las víctimas tuvieron que enfrentarse
Día tras día con dificultad a decenas de
soldados
los momentos difíciles para las víctimas
acabaron en ese momento
y continuaron incluso después de su
regreso a Corea
Japón ya ha pedido Perdón desde el final
de la guerra pero para muchos coreanos
son sólo palabras vacías de significado
en particular acusan a los libros de
texto japoneses de minimizar las
atrocidades cometidas durante la
ocupación
por parte de los políticos japoneses son
habituales los homenajes en algunos
santuarios del país donde están
enterrados criminales de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial tanto símbolos que
despiertan la ira de los coreanos sin
escandalizar a la mayoría de los
japoneses los coreanos son muy
emocionales Incluso en el caso de las
mujeres de solaz el gobierno japonés ya
se ha disculpado por eso consideramos
que el problema Está resuelto pero
siguen enfadados y exigiendo
indemnizaciones incluso cuando el
gobierno coreano dice que se está
ocupando del asunto se oponen y se
enfadan
el hecho de que el ejército japonés
pudiera hacer algo así en el pasado me
parece vergonzoso
Por otra parte si intentamos demostrar
quién tiene la razón y quién no será
difícil resolver este problema
el gobierno japonés no quiere oír hablar
más de indemnizaciones y considera que
ya ha hecho lo necesario en un acuerdo
anterior del año 1965 sin embargo en los
últimos meses un peligro común ha
obligado a Corea y Japón a limar las
asperezas y acercarse Japón se siente
muy amenazado por China y Corea del Sur
está en la misma situación ante el
conflicto entre Estados Unidos y China
y el ascenso de este último país Japón y
Corea del Sur comparten un interés común
en una señal de acercamiento A mediados
de marzo el presidente surcoreano fue
invitado a Tokio por primera vez en 12
años